it's about that time
debris this is C Mon Mary's dog we we
brought him into the studio once before
and told people at the beginning that we
would show them at the end I forgot
because he was a Brack tout but now he's
wide awake staring at me farting quite a
lot he does fart a lot
they're very bad today he's a good dude
yeah you can hear Chris lock and loading
in the background yeah so C Mon is gonna
be hanging out with us today when he
farts or when he gets I think I'm immune
to them cuz like I smell them all the
time so you're stuck in a room with him
for a really long no I can put him down
no that's alright what time is it okay
here we go
how long can you be
whoa who are the bad people
I'm gonna make it I was just like kind
of checking audio so I can't hear
anything
here's
who are you who are where don't like
this how you're supposed to play this
what is it at it should be out like
negative 15 yeah about that I just can
barely hear my voice well that is the
most important I wish the people could
see this but C Mon is like sleeping on
the dusk that we're playing on and it's
super cute really had a long day so I
told Mike but see mom went to the
emergency that last night had a really
bad allergic reaction and swelled up
really badly and I got nervous
I took noon he's fine but he's Hall
hopped up he's all hopped up on he's all
hopped up on roids I always wondered
wait how do I pop pills are one or but
you also have to bring them down into
your inventory oh [ __ ] I only have one
that sucks so we should I got a bunch
but I don't know that I can give them to
you cuz they're already in my like
hockey or whatever you wanna call it oh
I'm [ __ ] dumb never minds
I [ __ ] up I just added one pill
anywho so that's why he's here because I
can't really leave him alone right sorry
I'm just now if you can just realize
that like it might be the headphones oh
it could be
here's hoping but yeah the audio sorry
the audio has been weird yeah it's just
super when the hell am I going
oh so by the time this publish is like I
got a cool pretty pretty cool thing for
people to go check out I interned at
Game Informer in 2012 and I'm still
really good friends with a few of the
guys there and who used to be there so
when I was working there Dan Reicher
from Giant Bomb and then Tim Terry who's
at Capcom working on Resident Evil games
in rebel seven now as their like I'm the
marketing team we all were in Minnesota
for a wedding so we went into the game
former office to play rebel 3 4 episode
of replay they just go back through old
games that's awesome
um so I'm on that it's over on it
actually went up on a couple days ago on
my birthday so it was a nice like
all-around a nice occasion and res evil
3 takes place like right around my
birthday so there's a weird confluence
of a lot of cool things that's nice so
go check that out
they pimped we pimp Knievel a lot come
down this way really really what come
down this way or yeah I'm so confused
it's very confusing building and it's
got a door but I don't understand what
I'm doing what did I keep making me
focus on that cop car I get it is
burning cool
oh no we're supposed to go up what the
hell is going on that's nice are you
alright okay um up another flight maybe
no oh it's on this floor I see it I'll
tell you when I get the l1 shows you
know l1 literally tells you every turn
to make like hold on listening to you
know hold that one look at like I forgot
how oh wow right here take a look it's
like we've not been using it because it
really ruins you are done already yet
kind of dumb game [ __ ]
great we're back oh that guy's on the
ceiling
they have like little spider legs had a
big spider legs weren't they
um yeah they're pretty big still going
the right way we are passionate well for
whatever it drops all right you're so
hot they didn't really explain it did
they I mean they're kind of trying to
bat look
are those ha so dumb yes look at what's
happening I forgot about they're
dropping ammo at least should we be
shooting well I don't really want to
link how dumb does this look ok kick
it's stuck it's stuck on the pillar
we kill her - I tried shooting her yeah
no she's han again at first we're gonna
get the other
I'm rolling somehow these guys take
I feel like they should be stronger
I'm just shooting it nothing
here's Spidy Spidy Spidy Spidy according
to l1 yes according to Larry Larry
wonder where did you just go oh I just
got shot
oh okay why do they keep catapulting
backwards we kill them is that just is
that happening in your screen - yeah
they're weird beings we have guns and
then they're also spiders like she love
with us all right
guns spiders what's your opinion on she
loved the she loved being like an actual
sexy woman and shadow for have you seen
that no she's a huge spider but in
shadow of war she transforms into this
like attractively oh and like at no
point as far as I know I like tokens
stuff a lot she does not do that
she doesn't become a sexy lady
unfortunately no well would it that's
what she wanted
it's great that's what she was just
I'd rather she just still be inspired
okay well I watched Lord of the Rings
and I remember the spider scene she
wasn't cute yeah we're supposed to go
downstairs
I checked l1 oh he just went up to his
third hostage
how many spider carriages are there to
kill Rebecca they want you to channel
the car didn't do that again I pulled
the camera well sure how is supposed to
know this without this is sketchy
elevator also where do we go like I
don't I don't feel like I was really
aware of where we were you know we're
talking a lot and I have the game plan
for secured leaving the building now
okay that just leaves us
here we are it stopped now why it's not
a good sign
let us out so I can get through the
ceiling if you give me a hand up you go
what is going on oh it's you I just
pressed sickle should be able to come
toward the back yeah I thought it was
one of those things where you get to go
ahead
that should just kill us no I'm not an
RPG six
what beers
now they have saws
I kind of get in the feeling when I
welcome
there's no time for jokes
don't know that I can get over to you
well I took an RPG to the page
where's the do with the RPG oh I can't
jump sorry
or maybe I'm back I don't know all right
I do he wasn't a cutscene but I didn't
think that that would carry over again
take care of that guy sorry
oh right he's dead do normal things
kind of getting the feeling we're not
welcome here
such a you designed this left [ __ ] get
up you [ __ ] got a flash
oh wait what to get over did you see
that okay
that's right how are you supposed to
know
Brown that
[ __ ] shooting me is really annoying
[ __ ] get back get back back back
you're all getting grenades
they just turn into spiders with gun
how's it going on your end I'm gonna I'm
gonna flank them
quit having guns your spiders you have
to choose a path in life
[Music]
where are they well the music says they
ain't you know a lot of a video game
music that would be such a good play
though like if the music gets calm and
there's still dude out there kind of
like how resi will to get used to the
doors being these safe areas and then
that one door all right what are we
doing
now that I know I can hit l1 I'm doing
it a lot sorry
I wrote a song about a guy I met in the
bar yesterday and you want to hear it do
you like my hair do you like my style I
get it all the time cuz I'm the funniest
single guy in the world ladies get in
line you wrote that song about a guy
what guy diamond no I don't think you
listen to my song talking about me no
but it's funny no one made that
assumption
it's just a guy that I met
he was saved your life saved your life
copy that commencing with bombing
[ __ ] we're trapped what the hell do we
do now get out you can get out on the
third floor there's a balcony on the
west side of the building new mooing I
actually have a button that tells me
where to go thank you very much
Albert Jean get out of there now
preparations to find the building a
complete when rating a lot more
something flavor you don't want to be
here when those birds show your outside
well there were like jingles yeah
don't care that we're still in here
there anything like that just take
spiral you could really end off yeah
well my first try
accounting isn't gonna last long
[Music]
SiC
that seemed unnecessary
[Music]
come back
ah captain
that look so heroic on our part what
about when we both screened at the same
time
god we're cool
those men look
it's just in my day
you know yourself you're hungry
well there's a doozy boss in that
mission I would assume yes
we did it he earned a dog tag
good job
as a human oh yeah
and get the fence level - no I can't I
can't afford anything amazed we have no
money it's a long game
okay okay
you woke up see mom
it'll save my money
all right are you awake little man why
is he looking at me
what's going on here he was running
recon alone
now he did
where are we at all of a sudden Eastern
Europe we are a pretty positive
terrorism but we're in like although
everyone and we're sticking together
nobody's expendable exactly now each and
every one of you may be ready to die for
our cause but it's my job to make sure
we all get through this alive I know you
can all throw your lives on the line
sorry sir I know you're all named not on
my watch you're all dare stood yes sir
give us the update yes sir
the gorillas are using a new species of
POWs Command is calling them Java they
are extremely intelligent incredibly
strong and have the ability to mutate in
response to physical trauma all right
something we know enough about that
about walk around yes sir
Finn McCauley sir oh you're nervous Finn
the team's got your back okay
yes sir I'll give this everything I've
got
see always this awesome I was hard to
hear yeah he always
okay so we're playing a rectifier at the
two apart engaging the enemy my the one
the crash
copy that go it alone I got shot again
for an officer I get shot a lot Oh
hey soldier okay bye keep fighting the
good fight so weird they
crowd applause
I'm out of an 11-5 seconds
here's a question if this is a flashback
why is my ammo still
[Music]
and my help
shot that guy for you
I would choose a god for you
there's another one I just wrote another
son
machine gun good job it might have been
our sniper whoa okay so a little tiny
RPG oh I almost got run over going
really well to the beaches blew this
[ __ ] idiot with a knife
you okay soldier you're gonna make it
he's the new species HQ was warning us
about Jesus I feel like that bullet
bathed him yeah I don't know why you
said that Felix got the job soldier
new gun but like if you really want to
roleplay like you have to like feel like
god you're so cool if I wanted to yeah
that's problem
are we playing attack on Titan
whoa
this was not a rundown you know they
came in extra watch that
gonna throw a stick
[Music]
he may or may not be
run we've got a co W on our tails an ETA
pcs firepower now
[ __ ] with the point of this that was a
bad decision
that's why I'm the captain
oh I went over those
I
something
so you keep in risky
can we keep me distracted or you
he's mad
all right he's oh he's gone
[Music]
sorry shooting at me yes we gotta go to
outside
all right like I know that I made some
mistakes but I still feel like it was
the job all right you go into the
building up here so they tricked me
a bunch of jerks came around oh yeah oh
you're supposed to jump and then what
close huh
[Music]
before you mutated this was a young
Ukrainian child named Igor alpha w car
that's like nausea
it makes the whole bio-organic
like I trimmed in different
it's kind of like when
Resident Evil 7 had that candle put you
play I haven't but I know what it is oh
I know
like Simone's putting you in a war zone
of chemical warfare like a losing battle
why are we just in the goddamn truck
another wise perfect gaming experience
Oh
my [ __ ] out of it
[Music]
is he always this awesome great oh [ __ ]
I just got sniped like really close get
[ __ ] oh oh my god did that guy great
so glad it was
[Music]
when he was a young warthog when I was a
young wart
oh I made that up from the book of Mary
Merriman fuck-ass this Barbra Jean let's
see I was can you--can still get me I
was mixing plants sweet this is a
perfect time to do that nice healed you
as well here's a tic-tac
your breath imagine the the mocap actors
doing that doing what you want us to
what where's the empty of box of Mentos
into his mouth
[ __ ] man
[Music]
show your stupid head
the worse
they're turning into mutant
with bullets in them
bullet
[Music]
check the circle about my head I like
really couldn't make it any more clear
it looks pretty close
to our producer
but we don't get snipers sweet thanks
Finn why do we have to find him before
get up here's up
[Music]
Oh
no I need some of those bullets to hit
people
all right come this way go toward this
objective market you got it
while you're running for the explosive
you got to be close enough to it but not
look at it the blade safety to blow you
to safety
I hope it's clean status any casualties
oh it's your lucky day that's all we
take the whole thing is blocked off okay
zombies have a tank
are you watching are you playing the
same game I'm playing right now why are
you not up complaining about this I just
decided to accept it
get over there hot stuff yeah I hate to
watch you leave but I loved it lets you
top away see you later
whoa
I really like pretending that I'm a sexy
you're drowning because mission success
yeah I don't oh did I say no
I said I don't wanna play with you
anymore if you invite me again sorry I'm
not sure how
but we didn't lose any me to program
I wish people could see this so what
Seamon likes to do is he likes to lay on
the table but he likes to have one body
part touching a part of me so he lets
one of his feet dangle and then like so
he knows where you are
yeah so if I move he's like I know
you're not their best to let sleeping
dogs lie hey we're right here
you were so annoyed I didn't even know
what I was going to do I bet I didn't
even know what I'm supposed to do in
that scenario get over there I'll do the
same joke it's what you leave but I love
to watch but it was something all right
I'm gonna be honest with you I don't
know what to do like I'm supposed to run
over here and then it explodes
[Music]
okay I did it
no you win Finn how's our injured friend
still with us he's super dead Alpha Team
come in there's an old t42 check moving
on your position looks like it's had
some modifications
oh [ __ ] that guys I'm in this tunnel
fighting in close quarters with these
people because that seems like a good
idea
uh-huh for the game to make me do wait
where are the bullets coming the
question I'd like to ask
hiding is for [ __ ] get out of my way
well I'm really looking forward to
killing these guys with 30 boat just
maling doing a lot of points no I mean
sniper
oh I got sniped
I'm gonna need a bigger gun no [ __ ] you
that's actually some [ __ ] am I not
allowed to man this gun
[ __ ] you know like I have scope this
guy's got [ __ ] chicken legs and he's
karate kicking you're a dumb bad guy oh
my god
nice shooting Pierce thank you
all right this section coming sauce I'm
gonna die the section sucks
hold on stay alive good thing I have a
nice way to stay alive I'm almost there
man why would you give me this much [ __ ]
to do in ten bullets lake suite no one
in this [ __ ] [ __ ] game was like yeah
looks like make sure everybody drops
ammo everybody's dropping queen a bigger
gun what tank
come here chicken legs alright here I go
I got nine bullets
what is that I just saw that over here
like I have nothing fuel truck behind
the tank shoot it I have to draw the
tank no I got it now just stay alive
nice shooting piers
dumbest coming
I'm gonna try to hit this guy with my
super super great game where the [ __ ] is
my ammo for like as action e of a game
as it is that should give me more ammo
cuz like and and don't even tell me it's
a survival horror game because it's I
heading for the upper level of the
bridge meet me up on top I'm already up
here
[ __ ] stop shooting me I'm getting mad
might kill the sniper [ __ ] feel
vindicated yeah mister shot me so many
times
like I don't want any more points
they're useless piers over the ladder
come on up you go girlfriend why are we
climbing to the very top of a precarious
bridge because it leads into the tunnel
here's stop mashing sir I know what
you're trying to do you don't know me
reinforcements are moving in anti take
no one on this team gets left behind
especially gonna get even farther back
yeah but why when you're this awesome
parachuting zombies what a war wait
watch this one oh my got it we're gonna
fall look at my oh yeah get off my plane
next design he's gonna get a new
[Music]
oh that's my friend
are you ready straight at him oh I
thought that was the guy carrying the
dope
I thought it was her
was that you
my first time but I feel really
positively about this experience here
are the coolest captain I've ever met
I have no bullets oh there's Finn hey
okay Tom Charlie's gonna do that extend
okay I want you to blow the bridge okay
nothing like running from bullets and
faster than that guy all right what are
we doing
they can fin do everything bring him up
set two explosives the new guy he gets
the [ __ ] work
you're not getting started oh then
you're shooting at them
handi-quacks man
don't do it find cover
there's plenty of Christmas still back
covering okay blow it up wait
love it so unless you're gonna die
[Music]
Skoosh that really made splash sorry
this game is taking its toll
we're only like halfway through whatever
what do you say is that the episode was
about an hour is about now we're not
spoiling [ __ ] [ __ ] actually home let's
watch this cheryan Cheri Burcham Jake
again here in Raccoon City how do you
know that Claire wait are you Chris
my sister's told me all about you Chris
the man is wanted insurgency
yes he's a mercenary but right now he's
under the protection of the US
government he's no threat to the PSA
that someone pays me to be what did you
just say unless someone pays me to be
you heard me all of you
they're airlifting in
[Music]
we'll talk later right now you need to
find cover I get to be sharing bird
[Music]
oh they scared all right yeah
let me see how far away
he had to fart one more time okay see
you C Mon
alright buddy thanks for watching as
always we will be back next week with a
really dumb boss fight
oh there C Mon bye bye
C Mon say bye